hey there motion designers today we're
talking about a very important topic
that I get asked about a lot and that is
should I be a generalist or a specialist
let's discuss
[Music]
hey there and welcome back to the
channel today we're diving into an
exciting topic that every aspiring
motion designer must consider the choice
between being a generalist or a
specialist I'm Cameron with motion
science and as a fellow motion designer
I understand the importance of this
decision in shaping your career so let's
explore the pros and cons of each path
and maybe I can help you figure out
which one might be the right fit for you
but before we do I've got a little
something for you that will
revolutionize the way you approach
motion design and that is my new free
pdf guide called the complete guide to
organic motion design now if you're
tired of creating digital renders render
straight out of the box that just look
digital and they're not organic and
they're not tactile then this is the PDF
guide for you this guide is packed with
Insider tips and tricks that will
Elevate the look of your motion designs
to a whole new level of Awesomeness
consider it my gift to you because we're
all about growth creativity and pushing
boundaries together and this guide is
the next step in that Epic Journey so go
to motionscience.tv guide and download
your free copy right after this video so
let's kick things off with the
journalist versus specialist debate with
the pros and cons of being a generalist
motion designer generalists possess a
wide range of skills and they can handle
various aspects of motion design
projects so some pros of being a
generalist are number one versatility
generalists can work on a diverse range
of projects from 2D animations to 3D
animations to visual effects and a lot
more the next thing is adaptability
generalists can easily switch between
different styles and techniques and it
makes them very valuable in various
Industries and projects next we have
diverse job opportunities there's a lot
of diverse job opportunities for
generalists that means that they can
find work in advertising in film and
gaming in social media a lot of
different creative Fields next we have
collaborative they Bridge communication
gaps between Specialists so because they
understand the requirements of different
team members they're a great key asset
to have between Specialists and we have
flexibility generalists can handle
multiple aspects of a project this is
very useful for smaller Studios or
freelance work now let's talk about the
cons of being a generalist number one is
the depth of expertise generalists might
not reach the same level of expertise as
specialists in a particular domain then
we have Market competition as more
people aim to become generalists
competition in motion design can become
very high next up we have time
management balancing multiple skills can
be very challenging and lead to time
constraints on specific projects then we
have skill refinement it might be
difficult to stay updated with the
latest advancements in each area of
expertise because you're trying to
spread yourself so thin and then we have
a portfolio issue which is a diverse
portfolio can sometimes lack a clear
Focus making it harder to attract the
the right clients or the right jobs now
let's explore the flip side and look at
the pros and cons of being a specialist
motion designers Specialists focus on
honing their skills in a very specific
area which can lead to outstanding work
Quality Pro number one expertise
Specialists become highly skilled in a
specific area and they can deliver
exceptional results Pro number two
demand there is often a high demand for
Specialists as they are sought after for
their unique abilities Pro number three
is recognition being a specialist can
build a strong reputation within a
particular industry or Niche Pro number
four higher rates Specialists can
command higher rates due to their
specific skill set and pro number five
skill Mastery focusing on one area
allows for continuous Improvement and
staying at the Forefront of that field
now let's take a look at the cons of
being a specialist number one limited
scope Specialists might have fewer
opportunities if their Niche is not in
high demand number two niche shifts
market demand for a specialist expertise
can change over time affecting the job
prospects con number three collaboration
challenges in larger projects a
specialist might be limited to their
specific area and have less involvement
in other aspects of the project con
number four saturation if many designers
specialize in the same particular area
competition can become very Fierce and
call number five is skill gaps
specialization might lead to gaps and
other skills that could have been useful
in a broader role now as we've explored
the pros and cons of being a generalist
or a specialist motion designer remember
that the right choice really depends on
your individual preferences your career
goals and the market demands based on
where you live in the world some
designers find fulfillment in being
adaptable and diverse While others
prefer the depth of expertise and
recognition that comes with
specialization so what you decide is
really up to you I hope this video
provided you some valuable insights into
making an informed decision whichever
path you choose remember that continuous
learning and a passion for what you do
is always the key to success in the
motion design industry now remember I do
have a free pdf guide for you to
download over at motionscience.tv guide
it's my complete guide to organic
Mastery motion design and it is full of
tips and tricks that will Empower you as
a motion designer definitely check it
out as always thanks for watching today
and I'll see you in the next video
foreign
[Music]